[Music]  mm like we've never quite seen him  before  actually it's quite the opposite the  rapper is sporting more hair than ever  specifically on his face oh wait no wait  you kidding you didn't just say what I  think you did pity oh yes Eminem's  sporting dark hair and full facial hair  a drastic change from his usual bleached  walks and clean shaven face  [Music]  mm posted this photo to Instagram Friday  posing with dr. Dre and Kendrick Lamar  at the LA premiere of the Defiant ones  he hilariously called attention to his  new look in the caption just a couple of  guys from Compton and one from Detroit  with appeared  [Music]  but wait there's more here's another pic  of scruffy em hanging out with rapper 2  Chainz I'm different  yeah I'm different we got a say we are  loving em is a different look  you